I've been thinking about the gangster, Arnold Rothstein, the guy who's often credited with fixing the 1919 World Series. I've been thinking about his last words after he was shot during a poker game in 1928. Someone asked who shot him. "Me mother did it," he said. His mother. Even in death he was not going to rat. You know, at that point, what is the killer going to do to him? Naming his mother was nothing more than reasserting who he was one last time, in the face of death, who he was, which was a guy who would not rat.
我一直在想那个黑帮分子阿诺德·罗斯坦，就是那个被公认为操纵了1919年世界职业棒球大赛的人。我一直在想他在1928年一场扑克游戏中被枪杀后的遗言。有人问是谁开的枪。他说：“是我妈干的。”他母亲。即便在临死前，他也不愿出卖同伙。你知道，在那一刻，杀手还能对他做什么呢？说出他母亲的名字，不过是他面对死亡时最后一次重申他是谁——他是一个绝不出卖同伙的人。
And this is what we want from last words, let me tell you, this kind of summing up of who a person is. You know, sometimes you'll see those collections of famous last words that were printed in the paper or in the Sunday magazine, and they all have this quality-- they always do-- of pretending to sum up an entire life. Bing Crosby, "That was a great game of golf, fellers." WC Fields, "I've spent a lot of time searching through the Bible for loopholes." Oscar Wilde, "Either that wallpaper goes, or I do." And you know, the fact is, Oscar Wilde didn't even say that on his death bed. It's a remark he made to a friend at a cafe a month before he died. That's how much we want to believe in these things.
这就是我们对遗言的期待，让我告诉你，这是一种对一个人一生的总结。你知道，有时你会看到报纸或周日杂志上刊登的那些著名遗言集锦，它们都有一个共同特质——总是这样——假装概括了整个人生。宾·克罗斯比：“那真是一场精彩的高尔夫球赛，伙计们。”WC·菲尔兹：“我花了很多时间在圣经里寻找漏洞。”奥斯卡·王尔德：“要么这壁纸走，要么我走。”但事实是，王尔德临终时根本没说过那句话。那是他死前一个月在咖啡馆对朋友说的话。我们就是这么希望相信这些东西。
But, you know, we want our lives to mean something, and we want to believe that words can capture that meaning. And, seen in that way, last words, attempts at last words, a one final shot at figuring it all out, summing it all up, they have this way of asserting the fact of our existence at the exact moment of our annihilation.
但是，你知道，我们希望自己的人生有意义，也希望相信言语能捕捉到那种意义。从这个角度来看，遗言，或者说是试图留下遗言，作为最后一次理清一切、总结一切的尝试，它们以这种方式在我们要彻底消亡的那一瞬间，宣告了我们存在的事实。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Last Words. Several case studies for you. Act One, Actions Speak Louder, the story of people who were perfectly eloquent and the limits of what even the best chosen last words can say and do for people.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台和国际公共广播电台联合制作的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“遗言”。为大家带来几个案例研究。第一幕：行动胜于言语，讲述了一些虽然极具表达能力，但最终发现即使是精心挑选的遗言在人面前也显得苍白无力的故事。
Act Two, The Unknown Soldier, a story in which 40 voices become one voice here on your radio.
第二幕：无名士兵，一个让你的收音机里40个声音融为一个声音的故事。
Act Three, Rosebud, an act about which the less said the better.
第三幕：“玫瑰花蕾”，一个少说为妙的短剧。
Act Four, How the Living Use The Dead, Writer Greil Marcus explains what rock fans use dead rock stars for.
第四幕：生者如何利用死者，作家格雷尔·马库斯讲述摇滚乐迷如何利用已故的摇滚明星。
Act Five, Black Box. We go through transcripts from those black box flight recorders, the ones recovered from airplane crashes.
第五幕：黑匣子。我们将解读那些从飞机失事中找回的黑匣子飞行记录仪的转录内容。
Act Six, What Goes Through Your Head. We have a story from writer Tobias Wolff. Stay with us.
第六幕：你脑子里在想什么。我们有一个来自作家托比亚斯·沃尔夫的故事。请继续收听。
Act One, Actions Speak Louder. This is the story of people attempting to surround death in a web of words to better understand it, a very eloquent people and their last words and of what last words can and cannot accomplish. Page Smith and Eloise Pickard Smith were married for over five decades, and they died one day apart. In Santa Cruz, where they lived, they were well-known. She was an artist. He was a writer and historian, one of the founding provosts at UC Santa Cruz. Our contributing editor Sarah Vowell tells what happened.
第一幕：行动胜于言语。这是关于人们试图用言语编织一张网来包围死亡，以便更好地理解它。他们是一些非常有口才的人，讲述他们的遗言，以及遗言能达成和不能达成的效果。佩奇·史密斯和埃洛伊丝·皮卡德·史密斯结婚五十多年，他们相隔一天去世。在他们居住的圣克鲁斯，他们很有名。她是位艺术家。他是位作家和历史学家，也是加州大学圣克鲁斯分校的创校教务长之一。我们的特约编辑萨拉·沃威尔讲述了所发生的一切。
This is a love story, a death story. It is also a competition between actions and the power of words to describe those actions, between theories of death and the practice of dying. Before we get to anyone's last words about Page and Eloise Smith's joint life and joint death, here are the facts. I asked their friend, John Dizikes, and their daughter, Anne Easley, to tell this story. Anne recalls the beginning of the end when her mother was diagnosed with cancer.
这是一个爱情故事，一个死亡故事。这也是一场关于行动与描述行动的言语力量之间的较量，关于死亡理论与死亡实践之间的较量。在我们谈论佩奇和埃洛伊丝·史密斯共同的生活和共同的死亡之前的遗言之前，先了解一下事实。我请他们的朋友约翰·迪齐克斯和他们的女儿安妮·伊斯利来讲述这个故事。安妮回忆起她母亲被诊断出癌症时，那是一切终结的开始。
Early on, the diagnosis was not a good one for her. Like, within the first three weeks, we knew that it wasn't a battle that she was probably going to be able to win, but she went ahead and allowed a lot of treatment anyway. And I think that she did that mainly for my father. And then he had started symptoms, probably, beginning in the first part of her third month of her illness.
起初，她的诊断结果很不乐观。大概在前三周内，我们就知道她可能赢不了这场仗，但她还是坚持接受了很多治疗。我认为她这样做主要是为了我父亲。然后，我父亲大概在她患病第三个月开始出现症状。
And I talked to her doctor because Dad's doctor seemed to think that it was nothing important and was being very cavalier about it. And my mother's doctor told us not to be surprised if Father died shortly after Mother. And she had just met both my mother and father, but she could tell. And, I don't know, there must be something that happens when people who are that connected-- the doctor just knew right away. And she said that Father wouldn't live six months. I repeated that to my parents. I couldn't even believe it. It was kind of shocking.
我和她的医生谈过，因为父亲的医生似乎认为没什么大不了的，表现得很轻率。我母亲的医生告诉我们，如果父亲在母亲去世后不久去世，不要感到惊讶。她虽然刚认识我的父母，但她看得出来。而且，我不知道，当联系如此紧密的两个人在一起时，一定会发生某种事情——医生一眼就看出来了。她说父亲活不过六个月。我把这话告诉了父母。我甚至不敢相信。这简直太令人震惊了。
And my mother had had a major heart attack 10 years before they both died. And Dad told all of us, all the four children, that if she died, he would also die.
我母亲在两人去世前10年曾有过一次严重的心脏病发作。父亲曾告诉我们全家，所有的四个孩子，如果她死了，他也会死。
He said-- and I've never forgotten it-- "I've looked into the void." And it stuck in my mind very much.
他说——我至今难忘——“我已经凝视过虚空。”这句话深深地印在了我的脑海里。
And he never suggested he would commit suicide or anything other than he would just drop dead. He was just going to die. He refused, spiritually, to live without her.
他从没说过要自杀或其他什么的，只是说他会突然倒下。他就是要死。在精神上，他拒绝没有她而活下去。
There was something in the way he said it that made me realize that this person who was so strong, powerful, he exuded a sense of power, this person must have found the prospect of life without Eloise impossible.
他说话的方式让我意识到，这个如此强壮、有力、散发着力量感的人，一定觉得没有埃洛伊丝的生活是不可能的。
And he told us individually, I mean, just made sure that all of us knew, that that was the way he felt about it and that that was what was going to happen. And none of us questioned it. I mean, we all thought it was crazy and that he shouldn't do that and that there was a lot to live for after Mother died. But it was what he wanted. We just figured he'd be able to do it somehow, and he did.
他分别告诉了我们每个人，我的意思是，他确保我们所有人都知道，这就是他的感受，这就是将会发生的事情。我们没有人质疑。我的意思是，我们都觉得这很疯狂，他不该那样做，母亲去世后还有很多值得活下去的理由。但这正是他想要的。我们只是想他以某种方式能做到，而他确实做到了。
When the doctor said that your father would die shortly after your mother and you told your parents this in disbelief, what was their reaction? What was your father's reaction?
当医生说你父亲会在你母亲之后不久去世，而你难以置信地把这告诉父母时，他们的反应是什么？你父亲的反应是什么？
I think it was relief. I think Dad-- well, he knew he was going to do it. We didn't tell Mother, because we didn't want to upset her, until just a few days before she died. But I think it was also a relief for her. You're just going to have to accept this because I'm going to do it.
我想那是解脱。我想父亲——嗯，他知道他会那么做。我们没告诉母亲，因为不想让她难过，直到她去世前几天。但我认为这对她来说也是一种解脱。你只能接受这一点，因为我会那么做的。
That's OK.
没关系。
OK, good.
好吧，很好。
That's OK.
没关系。
Anyway-- but, as a matter of fact, I think that Father would have died, probably, right with Mother, if he hadn't been on chemotherapy. They put him on chemotherapy because he insisted on outliving her. He didn't want to die before her. He wanted to die after her. And he was actually having one of his chemotherapy treatments when we went and told him that she had died. And he removed the intravenous lines from his arms and said, well, that was it. He wasn't going to have any more medical intervention and that he would just be dying shortly, and he did. He died 36 hours later.
总之——事实上，我认为如果父亲没有在接受化疗的话，他可能会和母亲一起走。他们让他化疗是因为他坚持要比她活得久一点。他不想在她之前死。他想死在她之后。当我们告诉他母亲去世时，他实际上正在接受化疗。他拔掉了手臂上的静脉注射管，说，就这样吧。他不会再接受任何医疗干预了，他很快就会死去，确实如此。他36小时后去世了。
Those are the facts. As for the last words that try to make sense of that act, Page Smith wrote a column that does as well as one might hope. It was part of a series of columns he wrote for the San Francisco Chronicle in his last years on old age and dying.
这些是事实。至于试图理解这一行为的遗言，佩奇·史密斯写的一篇专栏文章写得尽如人意。这是他晚年为《旧金山纪事报》撰写的关于衰老和死亡系列专栏的一部分。
In the essay, he talks about the deep pleasures of lifelong coupling and, ultimately, the deep pain for those whom death does part. He wrote, "The consolations of an old marriage are the good news. The bad news is that one partner in a marriage, however idyllic, will pre-decease the other. Many years ago," he continued, "my dear old friend Josephine Jacobson, the poet, saw on a New England tombstone the unbearably poignant words, 'It is a fearful thing to love what death can touch.'"
在文章中，他谈到了终身伴侣带来的深层快乐，以及最终，死亡将两人拆散时产生的深层痛苦。他写道：“一段长久婚姻的慰藉是好消息。坏消息是，无论婚姻多么理想，其中一方总会先于另一方离世。很多年前，”他继续写道，“我亲爱的老朋友约瑟芬·雅各布森，那位诗人，在墓碑上看到一行令人心碎的字：‘去爱死亡所能触及之物，是一件可怕的事情。’”
In another column, called "Famous Last Words," Page ponders the quandary of the final thought. He said that he admired the last words of John Quincy Adams, who collapsed on the floor of the House of Representatives and declared, "It is finished. I am content." Page points out that the problem is that, in order for your last words to be famous, you have to be famous, which rather complicates things. He continues, "It casts a shadow over the whole enterprise. Maybe the proper thing to do is to die in decent, resigned silence, keeping one's final thoughts to oneself."
在另一篇名为“著名的遗言”的专栏中，佩奇思考了临终想法的困境。他说他很钦佩约翰·昆西·亚当斯的遗言，亚当斯在众议院地板上倒下时说：“完成了。我很满足。”佩奇指出问题在于，为了让你的遗言出名，你必须得是个名人，这让事情复杂化了。他继续写道：“这给整件事蒙上了一层阴影。也许最得体的方式是平静地、顺从地死去，把最后的念头留给自己。”
Well, of course, all of us were waiting for his final words. But it wasn't something where we asked him, "If you had your last words, what would you say?" And he slipped off into the coma before any of us would have done that.
当然，我们都在等待他的遗言。但这并不是那种我们问他“如果你有遗言，你会说什么”的情况。在他陷入昏迷之前，我们谁也没这么问过。
We live and we disappear. We come from somewhere and we go somewhere. And yet, words can remain. Writing can remain. Art remains. Art is long, life is short, as we know. And the last words, I think, are connected with that evidence that it's a kind of testimony against our obliteration and our disappearance.
我们活着，然后消失。我们从某处来，去往某处。然而，文字可以留下。写作可以留下。艺术可以留下。如我们所知，艺术长存，人生苦短。我认为，遗言与这种证明有关，它是对抗我们被抹去和消失的一种见证。
That may be true, but whose last words actually live up to that? Anne says that Eloise's final words spoken to her sister, Ellen, were, "I'm going to God." Page told his son to, "Give my best to everybody up at Cowell," meaning Cowell College at UC Santa Cruz, which he founded.
这可能是真的，但又有谁的遗言真正达到了那种高度呢？安妮说埃洛伊丝对她妹妹艾伦说的最后一句话是：“我要去上帝那里了。”佩奇告诉他的儿子：“代我向考威尔的所有人问好，”指的是他创办的加州大学圣克鲁斯分校的考威尔学院。
Historians, as an occupational hazard, live among the dead more than the rest of us. They talk to the dead, read their words, heed their warnings, try to give breath and blood to bodies long since turned to dust. The first important work of Page Smith's career was a two-volume biography of John Adams published in 1962.
历史学家作为一种职业风险，生活在死者中间的时间比我们其他人多得多。他们与死者交谈，阅读他们的文字，听取他们的警告，试图给早已化为尘土的躯体注入呼吸和血液。佩奇·史密斯职业生涯的第一部重要著作是1962年出版的《约翰·亚当斯》两卷本传记。
John Dizikes, Smith's former student, fellow history professor, and friend, delivered a joint eulogy for Eloise and Page at their funeral. I asked him to read it for me. It begins with one of Page's favorite anecdotes about the second president, the fact that Adams died on July 4th, 1826.
约翰·迪齐克斯，史密斯的昔日学生、历史学同事兼朋友，在他们的葬礼上发表了一篇致埃洛伊丝和佩奇的联合悼词。我请他读给我听。它以佩奇最喜欢的关于这位第二任总统的轶事开头，即亚当斯死于1826年7月4日。
Precisely 50 years after the Declaration of Independence and coinciding with Thomas Jefferson's death on the same day in Virginia, for Page, this extraordinary occurrence, to which he returned again and again in conversation and in lectures, the joint departure of two presiding spirits, two lives, two deaths, free will and necessity, unfathomably intermingled, suggested something far beyond mere coincidence. History is divine drama. "It could not be said that Americans were struck dumb," he wrote, "rather the reverse. They were struck into an outpouring of wonder and astonishment, of amazement and awe." And in these last few days many of us, too, have felt something of wonder, of amazement, of awe.
距离《独立宣言》签署恰好50年，且与弗吉尼亚州的托马斯·杰斐逊在同一天去世。对佩奇而言，这一非同寻常的巧合——他在谈话和讲座中反复提到——两位主持大局的精神领袖的共同离去，两个生命，两次死亡，自由意志与必然性，不可思议地交织在一起，暗示的东西远远超过了单纯的巧合。历史是神圣的戏剧。“不能说美国人被惊得目瞪口呆，”他写道，“恰恰相反。他们被惊得发出惊奇和震撼的感叹，满怀惊异和敬畏。”而在这些日子里，我们许多人也感受到了一种惊奇、震撼和敬畏。
The biography of John Adams was also a biography of Abigail Adams. And one of its most compelling aspects was the way past and present were merged, the 18th century and the 20th century, life and love, husband and wife existing simultaneously in the consciousness of the writer and of the reader, exemplified by the book's unforgettable dedication to Eloise, "through whom I know what Abigail meant to John."
约翰·亚当斯的传记同时也是阿比盖尔·亚当斯的传记。它最引人注目的方面之一是过去与现在的融合，18世纪与20世纪，生命与爱情，丈夫与妻子同时存在于作者和读者的意识中，书中给埃洛伊丝那段令人难忘的献词就是例证：“通过你，我明白了阿比盖尔对约翰意味着什么。”
Those are lovely words, an historians words, but sometimes there's only so much words can do. When the man John Dizikes talks about the uncanny deaths of his friends Page and Eloise, he ultimately rejects the poetry of last words for a kind of wondering. Anne does too. In the face of such a story, of such a marriage, who can resist comparing his own marriage to theirs?
这些都是优美的词句，是历史学家的文字，但有时言语能做的也就这么多了。当约翰·迪齐克斯谈到他朋友佩奇和埃洛伊丝离奇的死亡时，他最终拒绝了遗言的诗意，转而投向了一种惊奇。安妮也是。面对这样的故事，这样的婚姻，谁能忍住不拿自己的婚姻与之做比较呢？
I think many of us have wondered and thought privately about ourselves in relation to that. What Page and Eloise were and did may or may not be at all relevant to what we all are in our own lives. I do think, myself, that there is a quality of intensity of love that some couples have, of a necessity of being together, that many other devoted people don't have.
我想我们许多人都曾私下里对此进行过思考。佩奇和埃洛伊丝是什么样的人、做了什么事，可能与我们自己的生活完全无关，也可能并非如此。但我个人认为，有些夫妻之间存在一种爱的强度，一种在一起的必然性，这是许多其他恩爱的人所不具备的。
Oh, very, very few people will ever have what they had. And I have a wonderful marriage. I have a wonderful husband, but-- I don't know, maybe in 20 or 30 years, if we're still alive-- and we've been together 30 years already-- and if we have another 30 years, maybe we'll be as tight as my parents are.
哦，很少很少有人能拥有他们那样的感情。我有很棒的婚姻。我有很棒的丈夫，但是——我不知道，也许20或30年后，如果我们还活着——我们已经在一起30年了——如果再有30年，也许我们会像我父母那样紧密。
I believe that I understand how much Eloise meant to Page, just as he understood how much Abigail meant to John Adams and how much my wife means to me. There's a certain point at which you say-- not that life is not worth living, it is, but-- perhaps, that you've lived it fully, and there's no point in living a diminished life.
我相信我理解埃洛伊丝对佩奇意味着多少，就像他理解阿比盖尔对约翰·亚当斯意味着多少，以及我的妻子对我意味着多少一样。在某一点上，你会说——并不是说生活不值得过，而是——也许，你已经充分地活过了，过一种减损的生活已经没有意义了。
Page Smith once commented, "Often, the power of the original fact is so great you're awed by it." As Charles Adams said when his grandfather, John Adams and Thomas Jefferson both died on the same day, the fourth of July, 1826, "There is nothing so eloquent as fact." Historians, which is to say writers of non-fiction, spend their careers as fans of facts, noticing those moments when actual events have about them an air of magic, of myth.
佩奇·史密斯曾评论说：“通常，原始事实的力量是如此之大，以至于你会对其肃然起敬。”正如查尔斯·亚当斯在提到他的祖父约翰·亚当斯和托马斯·杰斐逊于1826年7月4日同一天去世时所说的那样，“没有什么比事实更具说服力了。”历史学家，也就是非虚构作品的作者，花他们的职业生涯去崇尚事实，关注那些实际事件带有魔法、神话色彩的时刻。
I think Page Smith, who loved his wife more than his life, would have appreciated the eloquence of his body's final act, dying when he did. Page and Eloise were cremated together, their ashes mixed. They're buried at the bottom of a hill. The marker, made by Anne, reads, "It is a fearful thing to love what death can touch."
我想佩奇·史密斯，这个爱妻胜过生命的人，会赞赏他身体最后这一举动的雄辩性，在他选择的那一刻去世。佩奇和埃洛伊丝一起火化，骨灰混在了一起。他们被埋在一座小山脚下。安妮制作的墓碑上写着：“去爱死亡所能触及之物，是一件可怕的事情。”
Sarah Vowell's most recent book is Assassination Vacation .
萨拉·沃威尔最近的书是《刺杀假期》。
Act Two, Unknown Soldier. We have this story written by Luc Sante.
第二幕：无名士兵。我们有这个由吕克·桑特写的故事。
The last thing I saw was a hallway ceiling, four feet wide, finished along its edges with a plaster molding that looked like a long row of small fish, each trying to swallow the one ahead of it.
我最后看到的是一条四英尺宽的走廊天花板，边缘装饰着石膏线条，看起来像是一长排小鱼，每条都在试图吞掉前面那条。
The last thing I saw was a crack of yellow sky between buildings, partly obscured by a line of washing.
我最后看到的是建筑物之间一道黄色的天空裂缝，部分被一排晾晒的衣物遮挡。
The last thing I saw was the parapet and, beyond it, the trees.
我最后看到的是矮墙，以及矮墙之外的树木。
The last thing I saw was his badge, but I couldn't tell you the number.
我最后看到的是他的徽章，但我说不出上面的数字。
The last thing I saw was a full shot glass slid along by somebody who clapped me on the back.
我最后看到的是一个满杯的酒杯，被一个拍我后背的人滑了过来。
The last thing I saw was the sedan that came barreling straight at me while I thought, "It's OK. I'm safely behind the window of the donut shop."
我最后看到的是那辆直接向我冲来的轿车，当时我想：“没关系。我就安全地躲在甜甜圈店的窗户后面。”
The last thing I saw was a boot, right foot, with nails protruding from the instep.
我最后看到的是一只鞋，右脚，鞋底有钉子突出来。
The last thing I saw was a turd.
我最后看到的是一坨粪便。
The last thing I saw was a cobble.
我最后看到的是一块鹅卵石。
The last thing I saw was night.
我最后看到的是夜晚。
I lost my balance crossing Broadway and was trampled by a team of brewery horses.
我在横穿百老汇时失去了平衡，被一群酿酒厂的马踩踏了。
I was winching myself up the side of a six-story corner house on a board platform with a load of nails for the cornice when the weak part of the rope hit the pulley sideways and got sheared.
我正带着一堆做檐口的钉子，站在六层楼角房屋一侧的木板平台上把自己吊上去，绳子脆弱的地方侧向撞到了滑轮，结果被剪断了。
I lost my way in snow drifts half a block from my flat.
我在离公寓半个街区远的地方迷失在雪堆里。
I drank a bottle of carbolic acid, not really knowing whether I meant to or not.
我喝了一瓶石炭酸，根本不知道自己是有意还是无意。
I got very cold, coughed, and forgot things.
我变得很冷，咳嗽，然后忘记了事情。
I went out to a yard to try to give birth in secret, but something happened.
我走到一个院子里试图秘密生产，但出事了。
I met a policeman who mistook me for somebody else.
我遇到了一个警察，他把我认成了别人。
I was drunk on my birthday, and I fell off the dock trying to grab a gold piece that looked like it was floating.
我生日那天喝醉了，为了去抓一个看起来像是漂浮着的金币，我从码头上掉了下去。
I was hanged in the courtyard of the tombs before a cheering crowd and people clogging the rooftops of the buildings all around. But I still say that rascal had it coming to him.
我在欢呼的人群面前，在挤满四周屋顶的人群注视下，在陵墓的院子里被绞死了。但我还是要说，那个流氓罪有应得。
I stole a loaf of bread and started eating it as I ran down the street, but there was a wad of raw dough in the middle that got caught in my throat.
我偷了一块面包，一边沿着街道跑一边吃，中间有一团生面团卡在了喉咙里。
I was supposed to get up early that morning, but I couldn't move.
我本应该那天早上早起，但我动弹不得。
I heard a sort of whistling noise above my head as I was passing by the post office, and that's all I know.
经过邮局时，我听到头顶上有种尖哨声，我所知道的就只有这些了。
I was hustling a customer who looked like a real swell, but when we got upstairs he pulled out a razor.
我正在纠缠一个看起来像是有钱人的顾客，但当我们上了楼，他掏出了一把剃刀。
I owed a lot of money for rent and got put out and, that night, curled up in somebody else's doorway. And he came home in a bad mood.
我欠了很多房租，被赶了出来，那天晚上，蜷缩在别人的门口。他回家时心情不好。
I was bitten by that black dog that used to hang around, and I forgot all about it for six months or so.
我被那只总是在附近晃荡的黑狗咬了，六个月左右我都把它忘得一干二净。
I ate some oysters I dug up myself.
我吃了一些自己挖出来的牡蛎。
I took a shot at the big guy, but the hammer got stuck.
我向那个大个子开了一枪，但撞针卡住了。
I felt very hot and shaky and strange. And everybody in the shop was looking at me. And I kept trying to tell them that I'd be all right in a minute, but I just couldn't get it out.
我感到很热、发抖，感觉很奇怪。店里的每个人都在看我。我一直试图告诉他们我一会儿就会好的，但我就是说不出来。
I never woke up as the fumes snaked into my room.
当烟雾潜入我的房间时，我再也没醒过来。
I stood yelling as he stabbed me again and again.
他一遍又一遍地捅我，我站在那里尖叫。
I picked up a passenger who braced me in the middle of Broadway and made me turn off.
我搭载了一名乘客，他在百老汇中间逼我，让我转弯。
I shot up the bag as soon as I got home, but I think it smelled funny when I cooked it.
我一到家就注射了那袋东西，但我煮的时候觉得它闻起来很奇怪。
I was asleep in a park when these kids came by.
我正在公园里睡觉，这些孩子走了过来。
I crawled out the window and felt sick looking down, so I just threw myself out and looked up as I fell.
我从窗户爬出去，往下看时感到头晕，所以我直接跳了下去，坠落时向上望去。
I thought I could get warm by burning some newspaper in a soup pot.
我想通过在汤锅里烧报纸来取暖。
I went to pieces very slowly and was happy when it finally stopped.
我崩溃得很慢，当它终于停止时，我感到很高兴。
I thought the train was going way too fast, but I kept on reading.
我觉得火车开得太快了，但我继续在读。
I let this guy pick me up at a party, and sometime later we went off in his car.
我让那个家伙在聚会上搭讪我，后来我们坐他的车走了。
I felt real sick, but the nurse thought I was kidding.
我感觉病得很重，但护士以为我在开玩笑。
I jumped over to the other fire escape, but my foot slipped.
我跳到了另一个防火梯上，但我的脚滑了。
I thought I had time to cross the street.
我以为我有时间穿过街道。
I thought the floor would support my weight.
我以为地板能支撑我的重量。
I thought nobody could touch me.
我以为没人能触碰我。
I never knew what hit me.
我根本不知道是什么击中了我。
They put me in a bag.
他们把我装进了一个袋子里。
They nailed me up in a box.
他们把我钉进了一个盒子里。
They walked me down Mulberry Street followed by altar boys and four priests under a canopy and everybody in the neighborhood singing the Libera Me Domine.
他们带着我沿着桑树街走，后面跟着辅祭男孩和四个撑着华盖的牧师，街坊邻居都在唱着《求主垂怜》。
They collected me in pieces all through the park.
他们在整个公园里把我收集成碎片。
They had laid me in-state under the rotunda for three days.
他们让我在圆顶大厅里停尸三天。
They engraved my name on the pediment.
他们把我的名字刻在了山花墙上。
They drew the collar up to my chin to hide the hole in my neck.
他们把领子拉到我的下巴处，遮住我脖子上的洞。
They laughed about me over the baked meats and rye whiskey.
他们在熟肉和黑麦威士忌的酒席上嘲笑我。
They didn't know who I was when they fished me out and still didn't know six months later.
他们把我捞上来时不知道我是谁，六个月后仍然不知道。
They held my body for ransom and collected, but, by that time, they had burned it.
他们扣留我的尸体作为人质并收到了钱，但到那时，他们已经把它烧了。
They never found me.
他们永远没找到我。
They threw me in the cement mixer.
他们把我扔进了水泥搅拌机。
They heaped all of us into a trench and stuck a monument on top.
他们把我们所有人堆进一条沟里，上面立了一座纪念碑。
They cut me up at the medical school.
他们在医学院把我肢解了。
They weighed down my ankles and tossed me in the drink.
他们把我的脚踝坠上重物，把我扔进了水里。
They gave speeches claiming I was some kind of tin saint.
他们发表讲话，声称我是某种圣徒。
They hauled me away in the ash man's cart.
他们用清灰工的手推车把我拉走了。
They put me on a boat and took me to an island.
他们把我装上一艘船，带到了一个岛上。
They tried to keep my mother from throwing herself in after me.
他们试图阻止我母亲为跟随我而跳水。
They bought me my first suit and dressed me up in it.
他们给我买了第一套西装，并给我穿上。
They marched to City Hall holding candles and shouting my name.
他们拿着蜡烛游行到市政厅，大声喊着我的名字。
They forgot all about me and took down my picture.
他们把我忘得一干二净，撤下了我的照片。
So give my eyes to the eye bank. Give my blood to the blood bank. Make my hair into switches. Put my teeth into rattles. Sell my heart to the junk man. Give my spleen to the mayor. Hook my lungs to an engine. Stretch my guts down the avenue. Stick my head on a pike. Plug my spine to the third rail. Throw my liver and lights to the winner. Grind my nails up with sage and camphor and sell it under the counter. Set my hands in the window as a reminder. Take my name from me and make it a verb. Think of me when you run out of money. Remember me when you fall on the sidewalk. Mention me when they ask you what happened. I am everywhere under your feet.
所以，把我的眼睛捐给眼库。把我的血捐给血库。把我的头发做成假发。把我的牙齿做成拨浪鼓。把我的心脏卖给废品贩子。把我的脾脏给市长。把我的肺接上发动机。把我的肠子沿着大道拉直。把我的头插在长矛上。把我的脊椎插上第三轨。把我的肝脏和内脏扔给赢家。把我的指甲磨碎混合鼠尾草和樟脑，在柜台下销售。把我的手放在窗户上作为提醒。拿走我的名字，把它变成一个动词。当你没钱时想起我。当你摔倒在人行道上时记住我。当人们问你发生了什么事时提到我。我就在你们脚下的每一处。
The Unknown Soldier was written by Luc Sante. We had 46 different readers, too many to name here, ending with the author himself.
《无名士兵》是由吕克·桑特所写。我们有46位不同的朗读者，多得无法在此一一列举，最后是作者本人。
[MUSIC - "WHO BY FIRE" BY LEONARD COHEN, PERFORMED BY HOUSE OF LOVE]
［音乐 - 莱昂纳德·科恩的《Who By Fire》，House of Love 乐队演唱］
Act Three, How the Living Use the Dead. Janice, Jimi, Elvis, some dead pop stars are so big you don't even need their last names. Then there's Kurt Cobain, John Lennon, Keith Moon, Jim Morrison, Sid Vicious, Mama Cass Elliot, Jim Croce, Ronnie Van Zant, Duane Allman. I could go on and on with dead pop stars, but I don't actually have to because, in 1979, writer Greil Marcus did it for me, for all of us, in the most definitive way possible.
第三幕：生者如何利用死者。贾尼斯、吉米、埃尔维斯，有些已故的流行歌星名气大到你甚至不需要他们的姓氏。还有科特·柯本、约翰·列侬、基思·穆恩、吉姆·莫里森、席德·维瑟斯、妈妈卡丝·埃利奥特、吉姆·克罗齐、罗尼·范·赞特、杜安·奥尔曼。已故流行歌星的名字我可以列个没完，但我其实不必这么做，因为在1979年，作家格雷尔·马库斯已经为我，为我们所有人，以最权威的方式做到了。
He had observed the ghoulish fascination that people have with rock deaths, how it's kind of gain for fans, sometimes, seeing which stars in their deaths come closest to who they seem to be on stage. Who comes close to meeting that 19th century romance slash James Dean ideal of living fast, dying young? And then he decided that the only way to deal with it was to make it into a joke. To settle the discussion forever, once and for all, he ranked 116 dead pop stars according to a complicated point system.
他观察到人们对摇滚乐死亡的那种令人毛骨悚然的迷恋，看到哪些明星在死亡中表现得最像他们在舞台上的样子，对粉丝来说有时甚至是一种收获。谁最接近那种19世纪浪漫主义式的或者詹姆斯·迪恩式的“活得快，死得早”的理想？于是他决定，处理这件事的唯一方法就是把它变成一个笑话。为了彻底地、一劳永逸地解决这个争论，他根据一套复杂的计分系统对116位已故流行歌星进行了排名。
Now, I had absolutely fabulous fun doing it. You know, very quickly, I was taking it really seriously. Well, how much is a suicide worth? And, depending on the manner of the suicide, do you get extra points or less points? And, oh, it was so much fun. It really was.
现在，我做这件事时获得了绝对美妙的乐趣。你知道，很快我就真的把它当回事了。嗯，自杀值多少分？根据自杀方式的不同，你会得到额外加分还是扣分？噢，那真是太有趣了。真的。
A classic example of something starting off as a joke and, suddenly, becoming an obsession.
这是一个从笑话开始，突然变成执念的经典例子。
Well, I got fascinated by this in the '70s, at the end of the '70s, when this whole notion of the survivor seemed to utterly dominate contemporary discourse. And I don't just mean in pop music. Bruno Bettelheim wrote this quite wonderful, long essay on the cult of the survivor, basing it on concentration camps, Nazi concentration camps, and the whole notion of what it meant to survive, and how, for some philosophers and artists, it had become the primary virtue, that nothing was more important than surviving, that it was a good in itself. And I noticed that, in music, there were all these records called Survivor, or I'm a Survivor, or I Must Survive, or I Will Survive.
嗯，我在70年代末对此产生了浓厚兴趣，当时整个“幸存者”的概念似乎完全主宰了当代话语。我不仅仅是指流行音乐。布鲁诺·贝特尔海姆写过一篇非常精彩的长文，论述幸存者崇拜，基于集中营，纳粹集中营，以及“幸存”意味着什么的整个概念，以及对一些哲学家和艺术家来说，它如何成为主要的道德准则，没有什么比生存更重要，它本身就是一种善。我注意到，在音乐领域，有所有这些叫《幸存者》、《我是一个幸存者》、《我必须生存》或者《我会生存》的唱片。
In USA , Rock Death in the 1970s: A Sweepstakes, which is collected in your book, Ranters and Crowd Pleasers , you list them. There's Grand Funk's Survival, the Rolling Stone's "Soul Survivor," Barry Mann's Survivor, Cindy [? Bowen's ?] "Survivor," Eric Burdon's Survivor, Gloria Gaynor's "I Will Survive," Adam Faith's I Survive, Randy Bachman's Survivor, Georgie Fame's "Survival," Lynyrd Skynyrd's Street Survivors, then The Wailers' Survival, and then the band Survivor.
在你的书《Ranters and Crowd Pleasers》中收录的《美国，1970年代的摇滚死亡：一场大奖赛》中，你列举了它们。有大放克乐队的《生存》，滚石乐队的《灵魂幸存者》，巴里·曼的《幸存者》，辛迪·鲍文的《幸存者》，埃里克·伯登的《幸存者》，格洛丽亚·盖纳的《我会生存》，亚当·费思的《我生存》，兰迪·巴克曼的《幸存者》，乔治·费姆的《生存》，林纳·史金纳乐队的《街头幸存者》，然后是瓦勒乐队的《生存》，还有幸存者乐队。
Yeah, and it's worth noting that all these songs called "Survivor" were different songs, or, at least, they had different words and melodies. I guess they really were all the same song. And, at the same time, Brian Wilson made a comeback with the Beach Boys, and everything written about him said he's a survivor. He was being praised for not being dead. And you reach a point when people are patting themselves on the back for not being dead, when they're celebrating their triumph over the dead, when they're affirming their superiority for not being dead.
是的，值得注意的是，所有这些叫《幸存者》的歌都是不同的歌，或者至少，它们有不同的歌词和旋律。我想它们其实真的是同一首歌。与此同时，布莱恩·威尔逊和海滩男孩乐队复出了，所有关于他的报道都说他是幸存者。他因为没死而受到赞扬。当你达到人们因为自己没死而沾沾自喜，当他们庆祝自己战胜了死者，当他们肯定自己因为没死而优越时，你就会意识到这一点。
Greil Marcus is the author of Lipstick Traces and other books including the upcoming book, The Shape of Things to Come: Prophecy and the American Voice.
格雷尔·马库斯是《口红痕迹》和其他书籍的作者，包括即将出版的《未来之形：预言与美国之声》。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "L'ANARCHIE POUR LE UK" BY THE SEX PISTOLS, PERFORMED ON THE ACCORDION]
［播放音乐 - 性手枪乐队的《L'Anarchie pour le UK》，手风琴演奏版］
Coming up, the voices of airplane pilots from black boxes and other last words. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，黑匣子里飞行员的声音和其他遗言。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, Last Words, people's attempts to make sense of their own lives, sum up their own lives, assert the fact of their own lives in the face of death. We've arrived at Act Four of our program. Act Four, Rosebud.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、记者和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目是“遗言”，人们试图理清自己的一生，总结自己的一生，并在面对死亡时断言自己生命事实的尝试。我们已经进入了节目的第四幕。第四幕，“玫瑰花蕾”。
[WHISPERS] Rosebud.
［耳语］玫瑰花蕾。
Act Five, Black Box. The most frequent contemplation we do, as a culture, of people's last words is when airplanes crash. There is the black box, which is frequently florescent orange, not black, which has data from the airplane's instruments and the taped voices from the cockpit voice recorder, or CVR.
第五幕：黑匣子。作为一种文化，我们最频繁地思考人们遗言的时刻是飞机失事的时候。黑匣子，通常是亮橙色的，而不是黑色的，它记录了飞机仪表的数据和驾驶舱语音记录仪（CVR）里的录音。
We wondered, do these voices tell us anything about how people compose themselves in the face of danger and death? Well, Malcolm McPherson has published a book of transcripts from 28 different crashes. It's less ghoulish reading than you might think, more like the movie Apollo 13 than The Bride of Chucky. It's full of technical talk and people trying to work things out.
我们想知道，这些声音是否告诉我们人们如何在面对危险和死亡时保持镇定？嗯，马尔科姆·麦克弗森出版了一本包含28次不同空难记录的转录书。读起来没你想得那么毛骨悚然，更像电影《阿波罗13号》，而不是《鬼娃新娘》。它充满了技术术语和人们试图解决问题的话语。
I think that, in general, what I've seen in these is the work of some extremely professional people, some highly-trained people who are doing what their training has instructed them to do to that last second, and some, in many cases, through the last second. And then, at one point, you just know, you can read and you can feel in reading these, that they know that it's the end game, that it's over. And that's usually when you get the kinds of emotions that you can read in these, the yelling and the shouting and the swearing which goes on. A lot of these people just end with, "Oh, [BLEEP]!"
我认为，总的来说，我在这些记录中看到的是一些极其专业的人，一些训练有素的人所做的工作，他们按照训练所教导的去做，直到最后一秒，在许多情况下，确实持续到了最后一秒。然后，在某一刻，你只是知道，你在阅读这些的时候可以读到也能感觉到，他们知道那是终局，结束了。通常这时候你才会看到那种你在阅读中能体会到的情感，那种咆哮、大喊大叫和咒骂。这些人中很多只是以一句“噢，该死！”结束。
Thinking about the different categories that these fall into, there are the ones where the crew actually acts very heroically and does what they can to save the plane. There are a few where people just seem to die out of sheer stupidity. There's one, a China Airlines flight--
思考这些被划分的类别，有些记录是机组人员表现得非常英勇，竭尽所能去挽救飞机。有少数记录是人们看起来纯粹死于愚蠢。有一个是中华航空的航班——
It was a China Northern Boeing MD 82 over Western China. It was in November of 1993, and the crew lost track of their altitude in a fog. And they were coming in for a landing, on a landing approach, and there are these ground proximity warning horns that go off in the cockpit. They're quite loud, and they are recorded in English. And, when they go off, they start screaming in the crews ears, "Pull up! Pull up," in a very flat, very loud way. And, these Chinese pilots and co-pilots, they were later overheard on the cockpit voice recorder after the plane had crashed, and the pilot was asking his co-pilot in Chinese, "What means pull up?"
那是1993年11月在中国西部发生的一起中国北方航空波音MD-82航班事故。当时机组人员在雾中迷失了高度。他们正在进行着陆进场，驾驶舱里响起了地面接近警告喇叭。声音非常响，且是用英语录制的。当它们响起时，它们开始在机组人员耳边尖叫：“拉起！拉起！”声音平淡而响亮。这些中国机长和副机长，在飞机坠毁后，他们的驾驶舱语音记录被窃听，机长用中文问副机长：“什么叫‘拉起’？”
The pre-recorded messages that the equipment puts out are all through these, and sometimes it's a little eerie. One of the most eerie times is Korean Airline flight 007, which got hit by a missile, and at the end of the transcript, the plane goes down. And, after the last words by any person in the transcript, the public address system recordings are still saying, "Put out your cigarette. This is an emergency descent. Put out your cigarette. This is an emergency descent. Put out your cigarette. This is an emergency descent," over and over after all the people are dead.
设备发出的预录信息贯穿了这些记录，有时这有点诡异。最诡异的时刻之一是大韩航空007号班机，它被一枚导弹击中，在记录的结尾，飞机坠毁了。在转录中任何人的遗言之后，广播系统仍在不断地重复：“熄灭香烟。这是紧急降落。熄灭香烟。这是紧急降落。熄灭香烟。这是紧急降落，”在所有人都死后依然一遍又一遍地播放。
Yeah, it's like an Arthur Clarke nightmare, you know? I mean, the humans are dead and the computers are still sort of living. How far those warnings were going on, I don't know. But they must have been repeated over and over as that thing plummeted from 50,000 feet. It was way up there, and it had a long way to fall.
是的，就像阿瑟·克拉克的噩梦一样，你知道吗？我的意思是，人类已经死了，而电脑却还在某种程度上活着。这些警告持续了多久，我不知道。但它们一定是在那东西从5万英尺高空坠落时一遍又一遍地重复。它在那么高的地方，坠落的路程还很长。
Let's go through a few of these so people get a sense of what these are like. There's one of the flights, Atlantic Southeast Airlines flight 529, this was August 21, 1995, going to Mississippi. And can I ask you to just read a little bit from where the captain says we can get in on a visual?
我们来看看其中几个，好让大家对这些记录有个概念。其中一个是大西洋东南航空529号班机，那是在1995年8月21日，前往密西西比州。我可以请你读一下机长说我们可以进行目视进场的那一部分吗？
"We can get in and land on visual approach without instruments." The control tower, "Good luck guys." The captain, "Engine's exploded. It's just hanging out there." The co-pilot, "Yes, Sir. We're with you. Declaring an emergency." The captain to the co-pilot, "Sin- single-- single-engine checklist, please." Co-pilot, "Where the hell is it?" Captain to the co-pilot, "Help me. Help me hold it. Help me hold it. Help me hold it." There's a vibrating sound as the stick shaker starts warning of the stall. Co-pilot, "Amy, I love you." The cabin, sound of grunting. Sound of impact. End of tape.
“我们可以进入并进行目视进场，无需仪表。”控制塔台：“祝你们好运。”机长：“引擎爆炸了。它就在外面挂着。”副机长：“是的，长官。我们和你在一起。宣布进入紧急状态。”机长对副机长：“单——单——单引擎检查清单，请。”副机长：“那该死的东西在哪儿？”机长对副机长：“帮我。帮我稳住它。帮我稳住它。帮我稳住它。”随着操纵杆抖动器开始警告失速，传来了一种振动声。副机长：“艾米，我爱你。”驾驶舱，传来咕哝声。撞击声。录音结束。
One of the things I thought was interesting reading these transcripts is how few of them have anything like the pilots or co-pilots saying any last words to their loved ones. There's this one where the co-pilot says right before the tape goes off, "Amy, I love you." But in the whole book of these you don't have any others where anybody gets any last words like that to anybody on the ground.
我阅读这些转录记录时觉得有趣的一点是，很少有飞行员或副机长对亲人说任何遗言。有一次是副机长在录音结束前说：“艾米，我爱你。”但在整本书里，没有其他任何人对地面上的任何人留下类似的遗言。
They're certainly not listed on these transcripts, the CVR transcripts. The NTSB, National Transportation Safety Board, which gets these things out of the black boxes, sanitizes them to an extent where personal or deeply emotional words that have nothing to do with helping anyone to analyze the incident, the crash, whatever it might be, they're not released to the public. In some instances, some of it gets through. But, for the most case-- and I think NTSB is absolutely correct in this, that-- it really has no business for the public to be reading this. I think that it's an issue between that crew and whoever.
它们肯定没有出现在这些转录记录中，CVR转录。NTSB，国家运输安全委员会，从黑匣子中取出这些东西，会将它们净化到一定程度，那些与分析事故、坠机或任何其他事件无关的个人或深刻的情感词句，不会向公众发布。在某些情况下，有些内容会漏出来。但大多数情况下——而且我认为NTSB这样做绝对正确——对于公众来说，阅读这些确实没有必要。我认为这是机组人员与相关人员之间的事情。
And so it's possible that, in fact, many more crews are actually trying to get in last words to their loved ones, but they don't get printed.
所以事实上，可能有更多的机组人员试图留下给亲人的遗言，但它们没有被打印出来。
Yeah.
是的。
As a reporter traveling around, do you travel with a little tape recorder?
作为一名四处采访的记者，你随身带着小录音机吗？
I do.
我带着。
And have you been on airplanes where you were frightened about it crashing and you've looked at your tape recorder and you just thought, what should I say here?
你有没有坐过飞机，担心它会坠毁，然后看着你的录音机，心想，我该在这里说些什么？
No, when I've been afraid on an airplane, Ira, I've been too afraid to turn on a tape recorder. What about you? Have you?
不，当我在飞机上感到害怕时，艾拉，我太害怕了，以至于不敢打开录音机。你呢？你有过吗？
I have, yes. I don't know what that says about me, but I have.
我有，是的。我不知道这说明我什么，但我确实有过。
Tell me. What have you--
告诉我。你曾经——
Well, most of the time I'm travelling, I'm traveling with tape equipment, I'm working on a story. And every time that I've been scared that the plane was going to crash, I have sort of mentally prepared, OK, what am I going to say into this tape recorder if this thing goes down? Who do I want to say anything to, and what's my obligation to actually observe what is happening around me? I mean, in a way, it's the kind of self-flattering melodrama-- do you know what I mean?
嗯，我大部分时间在旅行时，我带着录音设备，我在做一个故事。每次我害怕飞机坠毁时，我都会在脑海里做好准备，好吧，如果这东西掉下去，我要对录音机说些什么？我想对谁说些什么，而我观察周围发生的事情的义务又是什么？嗯，在某种程度上，这是一种自我奉承的情节剧——你明白我的意思吗？
Oh, sure.
哦，当然。
And, I mean, it's putting yourself at the center of a dramatic movie that you're imagining in your head.
我的意思是，这是把自己置于你脑海中想象的一部剧情片的中心。
Yeah. The thing that interests me most about the intrinsic nature of these transcripts is that I am fascinated by the moment at which everything normal turns 180 degrees in an instant. And, all of a sudden, everybody is-- in the case of the CVR transcripts-- everybody is in a pre-tragic situation. They're in an emergency.
是的。这些转录记录内在本质中我最感兴趣的是，我对那种一切正常瞬间180度大转弯的时刻着迷。而且，突然之间，每个人——在CVR记录的情况下——每个人都处于一种悲剧前的情况。他们处于紧急状态。
It happened to me when I was a kid and I was driving along one night at about 10 o'clock with my parents. I was 12 years old. It was in 1955. And we were driving along. My father poked along. He was a-- you know, whatever. And, all of a sudden, blam! Somebody stove into the side of us. My parents were killed instantly.
这发生在我小时候，1955年，我12岁，有一天晚上大约10点钟和我父母一起开车。我们开车行驶着。我父亲慢慢地开着。他是个——你知道，不管怎样。突然，砰！有人撞向了我们的侧面。我的父母当场死亡。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
And my whole life at that instant changed. It turned around. Things happened to me that were not expected, you know? And I think about that issue when I'm reading these transcripts. So I think that's what brought me to these things, why I'm interested in these things as much as I am.
在那一瞬间，我整个人生都改变了。它转折了。我身上发生了意想不到的事情，你知道吗？当我阅读这些转录记录时，我会想到那个问题。所以我认为这就是我被这些东西吸引的原因，为什么我对它们如此感兴趣。
Well, thinking about your collection of cockpit voice recorder recordings as an examination of how people handle that moment when the world goes from its normal trajectory into this sort of extraordinary trajectory where nothing is normal, the ones who come off as the most heroic are the ones who manage to keep themselves calm and keep themselves as much like they were still living their normal life, for example, Al Haynes from the Sioux City flight. Let me ask you to read a little bit from page 183 of these transcripts.
嗯，想到你收藏的驾驶舱语音记录仪录音，作为对人们如何处理世界从正常轨道进入某种非凡轨道，且一切都不正常的那个时刻的审视，那些看起来最英雄主义的人是那些设法保持冷静，并保持像他们还在过正常生活一样的人，例如，苏城航班的阿尔·海恩斯。请你读一下这些记录的第183页。
OK. The remarkable thing was the humor that kept going back and forth. I mean, there was a running joke in that cockpit.
好的。令人注目的是贯穿始终的幽默。我的意思是，驾驶舱里有一个反复出现的笑话。
Explain the running joke. Yeah, it's amazing.
解释一下那个反复出现的笑话。是的，太神奇了。
There was this guy in San Francisco they kept trying to get in touch with, who was part of the United maintenance crew in San Francisco. And he simply would not believe what they were telling him because, according to all his manuals and all he knew, this couldn't happen. The systems all couldn't go down the way they had gone down.
旧金山有个家伙，他们一直试图与他取得联系，他是旧金山联合维修机组的一员。他根本不相信他们告诉他的话，因为根据他所有的手册和所知的一切，这根本不可能发生。所有的系统都不可能像那样全部瘫痪。
Specifically, explain just how badly off these people were.
具体解释一下这些人当时的情况有多糟糕。
Oh, there had been an explosion in the tail of the airplane, which had severed the hydraulic control elements that turn the plane, and the only thing that they had to move the plane left and right and down and up were the two engines on the wings. And so they had no control except for these engines, and they had to control by the throttles.
噢，飞机尾部发生了爆炸，切断了转向飞机的液压控制元件，他们唯一能用来左右上下移动飞机的只有机翼上的两个引擎。所以除了这两个引擎外，他们没有任何控制手段，他们必须通过油门来控制。
So they would, basically, let up on one throttle and push ahead on the other to turn the plane to the right and-- yeah.
所以，基本上，他们会松开一个油门，推前另一个来向右转飞机，然后——是的。
Exactly.
完全正确。
At the bottom of page 173 there's this moment where Captain Haynes is talking to the flight attendant, and he's giving her the instructions, "OK, here's what we're going to do to evacuate. Here's the command I'm going to give you to brace for landing," and, you know, all that. He says, "And then, if you have to evacuate, you'll get the command signal to evacuate, but I really have my doubt you'll see us standing up, honey. Good luck, sweetheart."
在第173页的底部，有海恩斯机长与空乘人员交谈的那一刻，他给她下达指示：“好吧，我们准备撤离。这是我给你们的防冲击着陆指令，”你知道，所有这些。他说：“然后，如果必须撤离，你会收到撤离的信号，但我真的怀疑你还能看到我们站着，亲爱的。祝你好运，甜心。”
I know.
我知道。
And then she says, "Thanks, you too."
然后她说：“谢谢，你也一样。”
Isn't that amazing? It's so sweet. It's just so concerned and caring, you know? "Good luck, sweetheart." "Thanks, you too."
那不是很棒吗？太甜了。那只是太关怀和体贴了，你知道吗？“祝你好运，甜心。”“谢谢，你也一样。”
You know, just to get back to something you said earlier, you know, I can't decide if I think it's a good thing or if I find it a little disturbing that people's last words are edited off of these transcripts. I can kind of see it both ways.
你知道，回到你之前说的话，你知道，我无法决定我认为这是一件好事，还是觉得人们的遗言被从这些记录中编辑掉有点令人不安。我可以从两个方面看。
Well, I see it, pretty much, in line with the NTSB. And there's nothing we can do about it, as you know, but the fact is that why would you want to see, or hear, or read some of the words that would come off that would be just-- I'll give you an example of what these can be like.
嗯，我基本持NTSB的观点。而且正如你所知，我们对此无能为力，但事实是，你为什么要去看、去听或去读那些只是——我会给你一个例子，说明这些可能是什么样子。
There was a Turkish airline, DC-10 in 1975, that crashed in Paris. It was taking off going to London. And, as this thing was going down, the pilot started to sing a lullaby in Turkish, a child's lullaby. And it was extremely affecting. And it was just horrifying and, at the same time, it was so sad that this guy at that point knew he was seconds away. And this was his reaction. Why? What was going through his mind, what he was thinking about? God only knows.
1975年有一架土耳其航空的DC-10在巴黎坠毁。它正在起飞前往伦敦。当这东西坠落时，飞行员开始用土耳其语唱一首摇篮曲，一首儿歌。这非常感人。它既可怕，同时又如此悲伤，因为这名男子当时知道他离死只剩几秒钟了。这就是他的反应。为什么？他脑子里在想什么，他在思考什么？上帝才知道。
Malcolm McPherson's book is called The Black Box: All-New Cockpit Voice Recorder Accounts of In-flight Accidents. His latest book about a Navy SEAL's helicopter crash landing in Afghanistan is called Robert's Ridge.
马尔科姆·麦克弗森的书名为《黑匣子：全新的驾驶舱语音记录仪空难记录》。他关于一名海豹突击队队员直升机在阿富汗坠毁着陆的最新著作名为《罗伯特山脊》。
Act Six, What Goes Through Your Head. We have this piece of fiction from writer Tobias Wolff.
第六幕：你脑子里在想什么。我们有来自作家托比亚斯·沃尔夫的小说片段。
Anders couldn't get to the bank until just before it closed. So, of course, the line was endless, and he got stuck behind two women whose loud, stupid conversation put him in a murderous temper. He was never in the best of tempers anyway, Anders, a book critic known for the weary, elegant savagery with which he dispatched almost everything he reviewed.
安德斯直到银行关门前才赶到。所以，当然，队伍排得很长，他被困在两个女人身后，她们大声而愚蠢的交谈让他陷入了杀气腾腾的情绪中。安德斯本来就不是什么好脾气的人，他是一位书评家，以极其疲惫、优雅而残忍的方式贬低他评论的几乎所有东西而闻名。
With the line still doubled around the rope, one of the tellers stuck a "Position closed" sign in her window and walked to the back of the bank where she leaned against the desk and began to pass the time with a man shuffling papers. The women in front of Anders broke off their conversation and watched the teller with hatred. "Oh, that's nice," one of them said. She turned to Anders and added, confident of his accord, "One of those little human touches that keep us coming back for more."
队伍还在绳索处蜿蜒回转，其中一个柜员在她的窗口贴了一个“业务已结”的牌子，走到了银行后面，靠在桌子上，开始和一个整理文件的人打发时间。排在安德斯前面的两个女人停止了交谈，厌恶地看着那个柜员。“哦，那真好，”其中一个说。她转过身对安德斯补充道，确信他会同意，“这就是那种让我们不断回来的小人情味。”
Anders had conceived his own towering hatred of the teller, but he immediately turned it on the presumptuous crybaby in front of him. "Damned unfair," he said, "Tragic, really. If they're not chopping off the wrong leg or bombing your ancestral village, they're closing their positions." She stood her ground. "I didn't say it was tragic," she said, "I just think it's a pretty lousy way to treat your customers." "Unforgivable," Anders said. "Heaven will take note." She sucked in her cheeks but stared past him and said nothing.
安德斯自己也对那个柜员产生了滔天的恨意，但他立刻把这种恨意转向了前面那个自以为是的爱哭鬼。“该死的不公平，”他说，“真的很悲惨。如果他们不是切掉了错误的腿就是炸掉了你的祖先村庄，他们现在又在关闭柜台。”她坚持己见。“我没说这很悲惨，”她说，“我只是觉得这对待顾客的方式很烂。”“不可原谅，”安德斯说，“上帝会记下的。”她吸了吸脸颊，但盯着他身后，什么也没说。
Anders saw that the other woman, her friend, was looking in the same direction. And then the tellers stopped what they were doing, and the customers slowly turned, and silence came over the bank. Two men wearing black ski masks and blue business suits were standing to the side of the door. One of them had a pistol pressed against the guard's neck. The guard's eyes were closed, and his lips were moving. The other man had a sawed-off shotgun. "Keep your big mouth shut!" the man with the pistol said, though no one had spoken a word. "One of you tellers hits the alarm, you're all dead meat." "Oh, bravo," Anders said. "dead meat." He turned to the woman in front of him. "Great script, eh?" The stern, brass-knuckled poetry of the dangerous classes." She looked at him with drowning eyes.
安德斯看到另一个女人，她的朋友，正看着同一个方向。然后柜员们停止了她们正在做的事，顾客们慢慢转过身，银行里陷入了沉默。两个戴着黑色滑雪面罩、穿着蓝色西装的男人站在门边。其中一个把手枪抵在保安的脖子上。保安闭着眼睛，嘴唇在动。另一个人拿着一把短管霰弹枪。“闭上你的臭嘴！”那个拿手枪的人说，尽管当时没有人说话。“如果你们柜员中有人按下警报，你们就都死定了。”“哦，太棒了，”安德斯说，“死定了。”他转向前面那个女人。“剧本真棒，对吧？危险阶级的硬派诗意。”她用充满绝望的眼睛看着他。
The man with the shotgun pushed the guard to his knees. He handed the shotgun to his partner and yanked the guard's wrists up behind his back and locked them together with a pair of handcuffs. He toppled him onto the floor with a kick between the shoulder blades. Then he took his shotgun back and went over to the security gate at the end of the counter. "Buzz him in," his partner said. The man with the shotgun opened the gate and sauntered along the line of tellers, handing each of them a Hefty bag.
拿霰弹枪的男人推着保安跪下。他把霰弹枪递给同伙，把保安的手腕拉到背后，用一副手铐锁在一起。他一脚踢在保安肩胛骨之间，把他踢倒在地。然后他拿回霰弹枪，走向柜台尽头的保安门。“把他弄进来，”他的同伙说。拿霰弹枪的人打开门，漫步走过那一排柜员，递给她们每人一个Hefty塑料袋。
When he came to the empty position, he looked over at the man with the pistol, who said, "Whose slot is that?" Anders watched the teller. She put her hand to her throat and turned to the man she'd been talking to. He nodded. "Mine," she said. "Then get your ugly [BLEEP] in gear and fill that bag." "There you go," Anders said to the woman in front of him. "Justice is done."
当他走到空柜台时，他看向那个拿手枪的人，对方说：“那是谁的位置？”安德斯看着柜员。她把手放到喉咙处，转向她刚才一直在说话的那个男人。他点了点头。“我的，”她说。“那就把你那丑陋的［哔］玩意儿动起来，把袋子装满。”“这就对了，”安德斯对前面的女人说，“正义得到了伸张。”
"Hey! Bright boy! Did I tell you to talk?" "No," Anders said. "Then shut your trap." "Did you hear that?" Anders said, "Bright boy. He called me 'bright boy' right out of The Killers." "Please be quiet," the woman said. "Hey, you deaf or what?" The man with the pistol walked over to Anders. He poked the weapon into Anders' gut. "Do you think I'm playing games?" "No," Anders said. But the barrel tickled like a stiff finger, and he had to fight back the titters. He did this by making himself stare into the man's eyes, which were clearly visible behind the holes in the mask, pale blue and rawly red-rimmed.
“嘿！机灵鬼！我让你说话了吗？”“没有，”安德斯说。“那就闭上你的臭嘴。”“你听到了吗？”安德斯对那个女人说，“机灵鬼。他叫我‘机灵鬼’，直接出自《杀手》。”“请安静，”那个女人说。“嘿，你是聋子还是怎么着？”那个拿手枪的人走向安德斯。他把武器戳进安德斯的肚子。“你以为我在玩游戏吗？”“没有，”安德斯说。但枪管像一根僵硬的手指一样发痒，他不得不克制住笑声。他通过逼迫自己盯着男人的眼睛来做到这一点，那双眼睛在面罩的洞后面清晰可见，呈现出浅蓝色，边缘红肿。
The man's left eyelid kept twitching. He breathed out a piercing, ammoniac smell that shocked Anders more than anything that had happened. And he was beginning to develop a sense of unease when the man prodded him again with the pistol. "You like me, bright boy?" he said. "You want to suck my [BLEEP]?" "No," Anders said. "Then stop looking at me." Anders fixed his gaze on the man's shiny wing-tip shoes. "Not down there. Up there." He stuck the pistol under Anders' chin and pushed it upward until Anders was looking at the ceiling.
男人的左眼皮一直在抽搐。他呼出一股刺鼻的氨水味，比刚才发生的任何事情都让安德斯震惊。当那人又用手枪戳他时，他开始产生一种不安感。“你喜欢我吗，机灵鬼？”他说，“你想吸我的［哔］吗？”“不想，”安德斯说。“那就别盯着我看。”安德斯把目光固定在男人闪亮的翼尖鞋上。“不是在那下面。在上面。”他把手枪捅到安德斯的下巴下，用力向上推，直到安德斯被迫看着天花板。
Anders had never paid much attention to that part of the bank, a pompous old building with marble floors and counters and gilt scroll work over the teller's cages. The domed ceiling had been decorated with mythological figures whose fleshy, toga-draped ugliness Anders had taken in at a glance many years earlier and afterward declined to notice. Now he had no choice but to scrutinize the painter's work. It was even worse than he remembered.
安德斯以前从未关注过银行的那一部分，那是一座浮夸的老建筑，有大理石地板和柜台，柜员笼上方有镀金的卷叶装饰。圆顶天花板装饰着神话人物，安德斯许多年前一眼就看出了它们的肉欲、穿着长袍的丑陋，之后就不屑再去注意了。现在他别无选择，只能仔细审视画家的作品。它比他记忆中的还要糟糕。
The ceiling was crowded with various dramas, but the one that caught Anders' eye was Zeus and Europa, portrayed in this rendition as a bull ogling a cow from behind a haystack. To make the cow sexy, the painter had canted her hips suggestively and given her long, droopy eyelashes through which she gazed back at the bull with sultry welcome. The bull wore a smirk, and his eyebrows were arched. If there'd been a bubble coming out of his mouth, it would have said, "Hubba, hubba."
天花板上挤满了各种戏剧，但吸引安德斯目光的是宙斯和欧罗巴，在这个版本中被描绘成一只公牛从草堆后面窥视一只母牛。为了让母牛显得性感，画家让她的臀部呈现出挑逗性的倾斜，并给她画了长长的、下垂的睫毛，她通过睫毛回望着公牛，带着闷骚的欢迎。公牛带着坏笑，眉毛向上扬起。如果他的嘴里有一个气泡，上面写的会是“Hubba, hubba。”
"What's so funny, bright boy?" "Nothing." "You think I'm comical? You think I'm some kind of clown?" "No." "You think you can [BLEEP] with me?" "No." "[BLEEP] with me again, you're history. Capiche?" Anders burst out laughing. He covered his mouth with both hands and said, "I'm sorry. I'm sorry," then snorted helplessly through his fingers and said, "Capiche, oh, God. Capiche." And, at that, the man with the pistol raised the pistol and shot Anders right in the head.
“有什么好笑的，机灵鬼？”“没什么。”“你觉得我很滑稽？你觉得我是某种小丑？”“不。”“你觉得你能［哔］我？”“不。”“再跟我［哔］，你就成历史了。听懂了吗？”安德斯爆发出笑声。他用双手捂住嘴说：“对不起。对不起，”然后透过手指无助地嗤笑着说：“听懂了，哦，上帝。听懂了。”就在那一刻，那个拿手枪的人举起手枪，直接朝安德斯的头开了一枪。
The bullet smashed Anders' skull and plowed through his brain and exited behind his right ear, scattering shards of bone into the cerebral cortex, the corpus callosum, back toward the basal ganglia, and down into the thalamus. But, before all this occurred, the first appearance of the bullet in the cerebrum set off a crackling chain of ion transports and neuro-transmissions. Because of their peculiar origin, these traced a peculiar pattern, flukishly calling to life a summer afternoon some 40 years past and long since lost to memory.
子弹击碎了安德斯的头骨，穿透了他的大脑，从右耳后方飞出，将骨头碎片散播到大脑皮层、胼胝体，向后穿过基底神经节，深入丘脑。但是，在这之前，子弹在脑部出现的最初迹象引发了一连串剧烈的离子传输和神经传导。由于它们独特的起源，它们追踪出了一种独特的模式，偶然地唤醒了一个大约40年前早已被遗忘的夏日午后。
After striking the cranium, the bullet was moving at 900 feet per second, a pathetically sluggish, glacial pace compared to the synaptic lightning that flashed around it. Once in the brain, that is, the bullet came under the mediation of brain time, which gave Anders plenty of leisure to contemplate the scene that, in a phrase he would have abhorred, passed before his eyes.
在击中颅骨后，子弹以每秒900英尺的速度移动，与周围闪过的神经突触闪电相比，这是一种令人悲哀的缓慢、迟钝的节奏。也就是说，一旦进入大脑，子弹就处于大脑时间的仲裁之下，这给了安德斯充足的闲暇来思考那幅在他眼前掠过的场景——用一个他本会厌恶的说法。
It is worth noting what Anders did not remember, given what he did remember. He did not remember his first lover, Sherry, or what he had most madly loved about her before it came to irritate him, her unembarrassed carnality and especially the cordial way she had with his unit, which she called Mr. Mole, as in, "Uh-oh, looks like Mr. Mole wants to play."
值得注意的是安德斯没想起什么，考虑到他确实想起了一些东西。他没有想起他的第一个恋人，雪莉，或者在他开始觉得她烦人之前他最疯狂地爱她的什么，她那毫无掩饰的肉欲，尤其是她对待他身体部位那种亲切的方式，她称之为“鼹鼠先生”，比如，“噢，看来鼹鼠先生想玩了。”
Anders did not remember his wife, whom he had also loved before she exhausted him with her predictability, or his daughter, now a sullen professor of economics at Dartmouth. He did not remember a single line of the hundreds of poems he had committed to memory in his youth so that he could give himself the shivers at will, not "Silent, upon a peak in Darien," or "My God, I heard this day," or "All my pretty ones? Did you say all? O hell-kite! All?" None of these did he remember, not one.
安德斯没有想起他的妻子，在因为她的可预测性让他精疲力竭之前他也曾爱过她，也没有想起他的女儿，现在是达特茅斯大学一位阴沉的经济学教授。他没有想起他年轻时背诵的数百首诗中的任何一行，那时他可以随意让自己起鸡皮疙瘩，比如“宁静地，在达里恩山顶”，“上帝啊，我今天听到了”，或者是“我所有可爱的孩子？你说所有？噢地狱之鸢！所有？”这些他一个都没想起，一个都没有。
Anders did not remember his dying mother saying of his father, "I should have stabbed him in his sleep." He did not remember Professor Josephs telling his class how Athenian prisoners in Sicily had been released if they could recite Aeschylus, and then reciting Aeschylus himself, right there, in the Greek. Anders did not remember how his eyes had burned at those sounds. He did not remember the surprise of seeing a college classmate's name on the jacket of a novel not long after they'd graduated, or the respect he had felt after reading the book. He did not remember the pleasure of giving respect.
安德斯没有想起他垂死的母亲在谈论他父亲时说：“我早该在他睡着时捅死他。”他没有想起约瑟夫教授给班上讲雅典囚犯在西西里如果能背诵埃斯库罗斯的诗就能获释，然后教授本人就在那里用希腊语背诵了埃斯库罗斯。安德斯没有想起听到那些声音时他的眼睛是多么灼热。他没有想起在大学同学毕业后不久看到他们的名字出现在小说封面上时的惊喜，或者读完那本书后他感受到的尊重。他没有想起给予尊重的快乐。
Nor did Anders remember seeing a woman leap to her death from the building opposite his own just days after his daughter was born. He did not remember shouting, "Lord, have mercy!" He did not remember deliberately crashing his father's car into a tree, or having his ribs kicked in by three policemen at an anti-war rally, or waking himself up with laughter. He did not remember when he began to regard the heap of books on his desk with boredom and dread, or when he grew angry at writers for writing them. He did not remember when everything began to remind him of something else.
安德斯也没有想起在女儿出生几天后看到一个女人从他居住地对面的建筑里跳下自杀。他没有想起自己大喊“主啊，仁慈吧！”。他没有想起故意把父亲的车撞到树上，或者在反战集会上被三名警察踢断肋骨，或者在欢笑中醒来。他不记得自己是从什么时候开始带着厌倦和恐惧看着书桌上那堆书的，也不记得是从什么时候开始因为作家写下它们而感到愤怒的。他不记得从什么时候开始一切都让他想起别的东西。
This is what he remembered. Heat. A baseball field. Yellow grass, the whir of insects, himself leaning against a tree as the boys of the neighborhood gather for a pickup game. He looks on as the others argue the relative genius of Mantle and Mays. They've been worrying this subject all summer, and it has become tedious to Anders, an oppression, like the heat.
这是他记住的东西。炎热。一个棒球场。黄色的草地，昆虫的嗡嗡声，当街坊邻居的男孩们聚集在一起准备打一场比赛时，他靠在一棵树上看着。他看着其他人争论曼特尔和梅斯谁更有天赋。他们整个夏天都在为这个话题烦恼，对安德斯来说，这变得乏味，像炎热一样是一种压迫。
Then the last two boys arrive, Coyle and a cousin of his from Mississippi. Anders has never met Coyle's cousin before and will never see him again. He says hi with the rest but takes no further notice of him until they've chosen sides and someone asks the cousin what position he wants to play. "Shortstop," the boy says. "Short's the best position they is."
然后最后两个男孩到了，科伊和他来自密西西比州的表弟。安德斯以前从未见过科伊的表弟，以后也再也不会见到他。他和大家一样打了招呼，但并没有注意到他，直到他们选好了队，有人问表弟想打什么位置。“游击手，”那个男孩说。“游击手是他们所能打的最佳位置。”
Anders turns and looks at him. He wants to ask Coyle's cousin to repeat what he's just said, but he knows better than to ask. The others will think he's being a jerk, ragging the kid for his grammar. But that isn't it, not at all. It's that Anders is strangely roused, elated, by those final two words, their pure unexpectedness and their music. He takes the field in a trance, repeating them to himself.
安德斯转过身看着他。他想让科伊的表弟重复刚才说的话，但他知道最好别问。别人会以为他是个混蛋，因为语法问题羞辱小孩。但那不是原因，根本不是。是因为安德斯被那最后两个词深深地振奋了，那种纯粹的意外感和音乐感。他恍惚地走进球场，嘴里不断重复着那两个词。
The bullet is already in the brain. It won't be outrun forever or charmed to a halt. In the end it will do its work and leave the troubled skull behind, dragging its comet's tail of memory and hope and talent and love into the marble hall of commerce. That can't be helped. But for now Anders can still make time, time for the shadows to lengthen on the grass, time for the tethered dog to bark at the flying ball, time for the boy in right field to smack his sweat-blackened mitt and softly chant, "They is, they is, they is."
子弹已经在大脑里了。它永远无法被超越或被魅力所阻挡。最终，它会完成它的使命，留下那颗苦恼的头颅，拖着那条关于记忆、希望、才华和爱的彗星尾巴，进入那大理石的商业大厅。那无可避免。但现在，安德斯仍然可以创造时间，让草地上的阴影拉长的时间，让系着的狗对着飞球狂吠的时间，让右外野的男孩拍打他汗水染黑的手套并轻声吟唱的时间：“他们是，他们是，他们是。”
Tobias Wolff's story, "Bullet in the Brain." That's from his book, The Night in Question .
托比亚斯·沃尔夫的故事《脑中的子弹》。摘自他的书《疑问之夜》。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors for this show Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Amy [? Takahara ?], Seth Lind, and Sativa January.
嗯，我们的节目今天由我和南希·厄普代克制作，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德参与。节目的特约编辑有保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作协助来自艾米·高原、赛斯·林德和萨蒂瓦·詹纽瑞。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
［鸣谢］
Our web address, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our shows for absolutely free or buy CDs. Or, you know, you can download today's program and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网址，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们的节目或购买CD。或者，你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载今天的节目和我们的档案。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
［资助名单］
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who wanders the empty halls of WBEZ after each pledge drive is over saying--
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他在每次认捐活动结束后徘徊在WBEZ空荡荡的大厅里说着——
All my pretty ones? Did you say all? Oh hell-kite! All?
我所有可爱的孩子？你说所有？噢地狱之鸢！所有？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
What's so funny, bright boy?
有什么好笑的，机灵鬼？
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。